even that was so dramatic it gets worse
before it gets better
definitely they're not engaged Kim
Kardashian drop by Ellen on Tuesday and
spilled all the kardashian-jenner tea
like literally all of it really brace
yourselves because now we're breaking
down five things we learned from her
chat with the daytime host starting with
this Kim had to photoshop one of her
kiddos into the family Christmas card
I mean Chicago has a cookie in her hand
I was really holding some there st. was
really there but the rest of us were
there but North right it was a lot yeah
that cute West family Christmas card Kim
shared on Instagram recently was a lot
of work it's the most anxiety to get
four kids together smiling in a room Kim
didn't exactly get all four kids to
smile together so North was having a day
so she refused to be in the shoot the
next day she woke up and was like mommy
I really want to do a card so I said
perfect I called the photographer had
her come over and I said let's just
protect let's shoot us but cut me out in
a Photoshop foreign and it looks like a
beautiful card yes
she's photoshopped into that at our
lutely next up Kim dished on this
awkward moment I say Rob is number one
and then it would be like Chloe Kim
Kylie
[Applause]
yeah kendall Jenner ranking her famous
siblings from best to worst parent on
The Late Late Show to her defense she
did start it off with you guys they are
all amazing a parents
needless to say Courtney wasn't happy
about being ranked last I completely
understood that Courtney was sensitive
about that because she's an amazing
parent so Kendall just should have drank
or eaten a tarantula whatever she had to
go you got to take one for the family
team and speaking of Kourt she doesn't
want to show up she doesn't want to work
she has too many boundaries she's out
Kim gave fans an update on where things
stand between her and her big sis
following their super tense feud on the
latest season of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians we've really taken the time
to hear each other out and listen what
sucks is that season 18 will come out
soon and it gets worse before it gets
better so her and I appealed and have
talked about everything just a refresher
Kim and Chloe confronted Court on the
family's hit reality show about her
boundaries with filming our job is being
open and honest and sharing a lot of
ourselves and it just seems like for the
past few years now Kourtney hasn't
really been open about her personal life
on camera
well Kim made sure to set the record
straight about all of that - Courtney
doesn't want to be a part of it anymore
she doesn't like getting photographed
shows and like her privacy exposed and
she's saying she does what about though
she likes it but only she wants to film
just when she feels like it but again
Kim says it's all good now we're in a
good place about respecting each other's
space and if someone doesn't want to be
on the show we obviously want them to
have that mental break and live their
life exactly the way that they want ETS
court about the whole ordeal when we sat
down with the Kardashian sisters in
October you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there but
I'm not saying goodbye do you think the
show can continue going if you lose a
sister we definitely love Courtney we
will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time this family we are feel
like it's a revolving door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back and last but
not least Kim played coy when asked
about the rumors at her little sis Kylie
had gotten back together with Travis
Scott um no I honestly don't know but I
think that they are just really close
friends isn't in co-parenting amazingly
yeah that doesn't exactly sound like a
denial to me of course Kylie and Travis
split in October and share a
one-year-old daughter stormy together
but what about that diamond ring Kylie's
been spotted sporting the big ring
definitely they're not engaged mm-hmm
and I think she's wearing it on a
different finger okay um I do know that
she I think she bought that herself
to do that
but yeah I don't know the status if
they're together or not I don't think
they are the Kardashians really are the
gift that keeps on giving of course you
can count on et to help you keep up with
the Kardashian Jenner's so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Holly Stephens
see you soon
[Music]